barrie on est très heureux de te voir à
paris après si longtemps
j'ai vraiment le comeback de l'année ça
fait du bien d'entendre
enregistré plus de 100 disques et puis
tout d'un coup tu as disparu qu'est ce
qui s'est passé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu des petits problèmes avec ma
maison de disques
j'ai essayé d'arranger ça
trouver des contrats mais ça n'a pas
marché
ça a duré cinq ans
après je me suis un peu retirée par an
deux ans et demi pour ménager ma vie
privée pour essayer de trouver des fonds
pour la maison wendel
quand j'ai vu que j'arrivais pas
gêné c'est de reprendre ma carrière
poursuit la
visite chose là-dessus tout fait c'est
vrai que tu contribues beaucoup aux
oeuvres de charité pour les ghettos
ouais
depuis toujours
je viens moi-même du ghetto je viens des
quartiers pauvres de los angeles
j'étais un petit voyou et j'ai eu des
ennuis quand j'étais adolescent dépend
des grands trajets
alors je comprend les problèmes des gens
pauvres ceux qui sont vraiment
défavorisés pour les pour vous j'essaie
de les aider c'est pas le jeu
fallu combien de temps pour devenir star
a pris 11 ans et demi c'est vraiment
très très long
à ta remarque est un truc c'est que dans
le monde les gens avaient couleurs
différentes il avait les cuisines
différents mais il avait des trucs
différents mais qu'un truc qu'ils aient
tous c'était faire l'amour chanté
l'amour ça marche partout
c'est ça ton secret on a passé le plus
grand dénominateur commun
[Applaudissements]
et des gens qui disent baril on a
tellement écouté tes disques en faisant
l'amour qu'on a l'impression que des
fois tu mets en garde
c'est pas gênant de rentrer comme ça
dans la vie privée des gens
non ça c'est le plus beau compliment
qu'on puisse faire à la musique de paris
j'ai vraiment beaucoup de chance les
gens accorde une telle importance à la
musique qu'ils veulent qu'elle participe
à la relation les plus lus et les plus
intimes je leur en suis très
reconnaissant l amour sur un disque
barioz a
alors deux mois tard cette 90e un
cocktail appelé le cocktail barry white
ce serait quoi la recette
la recette c'est
c'est la passion la justice le travail
la loyauté
parce qu'on fait être honnête dans ce
qu'on fait de
vous trouver un thème dont on a envie
que par et
barry white c'est l'amour d'autres c'est
la guerre
je suis une force positive
est temps que le monde continuera à se
perpétuer entre dans vie tant que les
gens continueront à faire l'amour temps
qui se multiplieront barry white sera là
avec eux chefs libère c'est ça la
recette
ses dernières chansons s'appelle the
right man
c'est quoi pour toi light night
imagine tu rencontres une fine nuit ce
serait quoi pour toi là reitman
[Musique]
accomplir tout ce que j'ai envie d'un
couple est
allé tous les cd l'homme en train de
faire l'amour
adoré cette femme
ce qui fait que tout comme quand il est
avec une femme dont il aime beaucoup
partagé la compagnie
nous les hommes on imagine tout un plan
quand une femme est parfois les choses
se passent pas comme prévu parce que
c'est pas la bonne nuit ou que c'est pas
le bon moment mais si c'est la bonne
nuit avec un peu de musique de barry
white ça marche
ce soir tu as concert au zénith dépêche
toi tu veux être en retard travail
allait bientôt tu vas être sur scène
ça va durer deux heures deux heures
qu'est ce que tu souhaites exprimé aux
gens pour cette fin d'année
mon amour ma reconnaissance pour l'année
qui vient de s'écouler l'espoir d'une
année nouvelle encore plus prospère
le message c'est
musique et l'amour
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu